pick any star in the night sky we might
know its name
what kind of star it is and how far away
it is
but we probably don't know its age stars
don't exactly come with a birth
certificate
even for our own sun we know how big it
is how massive it is
what it's made of but we can't tell how
long it's been there just by looking at
it
star ages might help us figure out how
galaxies grow and evolve
how planets form and maybe even assist
in the search for life in other solar
systems
so how do you measure the age of a star
scientists have to estimate the star's
age by looking at things like its spin
and its brightness
and those things depend on where a star
is in its life cycle
the average star is born from a spinning
cloud of gas that collapses in on itself
the gas at the center gets so hot and
dense that it sparks
nuclear fusion turning hydrogen into
helium
this fuel jump starts the star's engine
the star spends most of its life with
its engine running
as a star matures its core condenses and
this hydrogen
burning zone moves toward the surface
when a star runs out of hydrogen fuel in
its core
it enters retirement the star cools down
at the surface and becomes a red giant
some stars continue fusing helium and
other elements into
even heavier elements before they die
and in the finale of this life cycle
smaller stars release the rest of their
gas into space
while more massive ones can go supernova
a star's life span and its ultimate fate
are set by its mass more massive stars
burn through their fuel more quickly and
may only live
a few million years less massive stars
like our sun
use their fuel more slowly and stick
around for 10 billion years or more that
means two stars could be the same age
but in totally different phases of their
lives
every galaxy is littered with clusters
of stars
and while stars in the same cluster burn
fuel at different speeds
they were probably all born around the
same time that means scientists can
ballpark the age of a group of stars by
figuring out which ones have just run
out of fuel
they do that by plotting the stars on a
hertzsprung russell diagram
or hr diagram take the pleiades cluster
in the constellation taurus
measure the brightness and temperature
of each star and plot them on this graph
the stars that are still burning
hydrogen in their cores
follow along this line here scientists
call this
the main sequence the pleiades are about
a hundred million years old
all but the most massive stars are still
on the main sequence
when those stars reach their twilight
years they will veer off that path and
end up over here
the most massive stars leave the main
sequence first
figuring out which stars have most
recently made that turn
tells you that those stars have just
used up all of the hydrogen fuel in
their cores
based on previous calculations
scientists know how long that should
take
and thus how long ago the stars began to
twinkle
if the star you're curious about happens
to be in a cluster hr diagrams are great
but it's a lot harder to gauge the age
of a single star
one way is to measure how fast the star
spins
surface activity star spots and the
spectrum of light the star emits
can tell scientists a star's rotation
speed
in the 1970s astronomers noticed that
stars
and young clusters spin faster than
stars in older clusters
that observation led to an equation that
can convert
spin into age more or less but rotation
is hard to measure
measuring the rotation rate of every
star in the universe is impractical
and for some stars it's simply
impossible for now
the most accurate way to measure the age
of a single star is by tracking
how its brightness changes over time
those periodic
changes reflect pulses and shivers
inside the star
this stellar seismology can tell us how
dense the core is
and how much hydrogen the star has
converted into helium
the more hydrogen in the core the
younger the star
to do this you need to point a really
good space telescope at a star
for a long time that's what the kepler
space telescope did when it was looking
for exoplanets
to the exoplanet scientists any data
that didn't show a planet was trash
but to stellar physicists it was
treasure the kepler observations showed
something surprising
stars eventually stop slowing down one
stars have burned about
half of their fuel they may keep the
same rotation rates for the rest of
their lives
that makes spin an unreliable proxy for
stars beyond middle age
and confirms that brightness provides
more accurate numbers
new telescopes will follow in kepler's
footsteps
and could provide even better age
estimates for the stars they observe
a star's age is more than just a fun
fact about stars we recognize in the
night sky
better age estimates for stars in the
milky way could help us
understand the evolution of the galaxy
and our own star
and of course there's aliens when we
find life on another planet
we'll want to know how long it's been
there knowing the age of the star can
tell you roughly the age of the planet
and that can give you an idea of how
long it took for that life to get going
so when you ask how old is that star
you're asking one of the most
fundamental questions
in the universe
[Music]
so when i made my first hr diagram in
college as part of
a class that was when i realized for the
first time
that's the only way you can tell how old
a star is and that kind of blew my mind
i was like that's all
that's the best we can do like this is
such a basic
thing and you can measure i thought for
sure you could tell from like the
spectrum or something but no you can't
you're gonna be famous you're gonna be
on youtube